going back to the women in peril what
are some some scenarios where the peril
is not too dark
you know i've watched lifetime movies
for years and i i actually enjoy them as
much as you can kind of
see the cliche scenario that happens all
the time but what are these
these women in peril stories how do they
usually end up of course
and and what's too dark you don't if it
feels more like a law and order as the
you episode that's too dark you want it
you can do like a don't take my baby
movie which is like an adoption scenario
that's gone wrong
but the baby cannot be in like physical
jeopardy
you can have the the vigilante
female who has been wronged by the
system
and she has to take justice into her own
hands
you know she can she can go
you know take revenge on males but it's
not like a murder spree it's more like
uh
she's gonna get back at them by hurting
them or it hurts most and i don't mean a
knock to the balls i'm talking about
like ruining their business
showcasing them as a cheater to their
spouse you know this kind of stuff
ruining their lives in that sense like a
smart tactical strategic way of doing it
uh that's more the the theme behind it
and this female in peril again
who is she like what she can't be from
a bad neighborhood right she has to be
still middle class college educated
yeah nice girl maybe did a couple bad
things right
we've all done a couple bad things and
she's very reflective of just the
average human experience but she should
be
you know youngish
middle-aged maybe um and it's
essentially just
she did all the right she made all the
right decisions in life she did
everything that she was supposed to do
uh and somehow or another
life has just kind of wronged her the
man that she married turned out to be
abusive or a cheater or maybe he's
corrupt and he's getting
arrested for embezzlement she's doing
all the right things to
help a young mother in need with her
infant
and then it just turns into a nightmare
she makes
one mistake uh thinking that it's not a
big deal
um and she's just following her heart
and then it turns out to be a nightmare
it's like the reverse fatal attraction
scenario i mean it's it's all kinds of
stuff like that
but it they should not they should be
reflective of just a normal person who's
just doing the right thing
who just gets caught up in something
that they never expected to have
happened to him and it's even better
when they're doing what they think is
right and the system wrongs them
and why wouldn't we want to see someone
that's a little bit
off that maybe we wouldn't be but it's
kind of interesting like you see someone
at the bus stop and you think wow i
wonder what their life is like
why wouldn't most people want to see
that what because it's not reflective of
them
and they're scared of it i just find
that fascinating they just yeah they
can't identify with it as easily
and so if they can't truly put
themselves into that lifestyle and truly
see how this character
could be you know like an evolution of
themselves
uh it's just more difficult to grasp on
to it's either got to be
like something that they see that they
they could have been
something they wished they could have
been something along those lines those
are really the stories that that really
they talk about like the the
character is more interesting
and the reason why is because we all
wish we had that bite where we could
just go say those things and do those
things and behave that way
it's an evolution of what we wished we
could see it's kind of a fantasy
but but there has to be something within
that character we identify with
even somebody as evil is like alex on a
clockwork orange or something like that
you know it's it's at the end of the day
it's
there has to be some element in that
character that we can see
and that's what it is